thank you
good morning everybody and welcome to
this latest meeting of the public
covered public engagement board
of trafford council first item on the
agenda is attendances
i have apologies today from eleanor roof
who's taking a well-deserved
break sarah ladcliffe councillors welton
evans and chilton are there any more
apologies
i don't see any thank you can i also
thank you all for your attendance today
are there any declarations of interest
in any of the agenda items on
uh the list this morning please
yeah judith
can i just uh declare that i am a
trustee of jesus
which is referenced further into the
report
will help thank you for bringing that to
our attention
thank you julie uh i don't see any
further
um minutes of the last meeting please
can i take those as read
i can accept them as a true and accurate
record
thank you and moving swiftly on then to
item four the update
on the current kovid 19 situation in
trafford
with helen thank you very much helen
thank you chair
um so the update um i wish i could tell
you
that our rates are going down but
unfortunately they are continuing to
increase
so as at the 24th of june for the
previous seven days our rate was 295 per
hundred thousand
so that's uh 702 new cases of covid in
trafford across that time period
for the seven days before that we were
at 241 per hundred thousand
so you can see within seven days we've
increased by 50 per 100
000 at this point um
so that's where we currently are in
terms of our age groups it is our under
30s
so our 60 and over is stable at the
moment it's it's a very
um low rate but it is our 10
to 30 age group that is causing us um
a lot of activity at the moment in
particular
the 15 to 29 age group has a rate of 657
per hundred thousand so you can just see
um the rates there within that
population
and what we would say is this very much
is the delta variant being more
transmissible
but it's also um the success of the
vaccine program
in terms of that coverage for the older
population as well
so um so that's where we're in terms of
age groups
i guess the main thing as children's
lead for public health
is just to obviously touch on the
schools as i'm aware that there's been a
huge amount of discussion in schools
uh around the activities in schools so
as a as a borough
we we are eighth in greater manchester
18th in england in terms of our rates
and in terms of our geographies it's uh
the west so ernst scenario partington
the north obviously is where our hyper
risk area is
saint mary's and sale which is um quite
central i think it's the m33 and davey
hume
where our rates are the highest and
that's very much reflected in our
schools
in terms of the schools that we are
working with as an outbreak team and
last week and the week before we are
busy
and there are lots of cases so we
currently are working with 56 different
schools and that's just in terms of
activity
but in terms of outbreaks we are working
with um
13 schools around outbreaks and just to
reassure colleagues
we are very well versed now in outbreak
management in schools
and we have a really good process we
work very closely with our education
colleagues
with the schools and with the governors
so we do have a program that we set in
place as soon as we are aware of any
issues within a school
the other area obviously is within early
years so we are working with a number of
early years settings and nurseries
and three of those have outbreaks at the
moment
um the other issue i guess really is
just to talk about hospitality level
leisure and shopping so um that's
another area where we have seen
activities this week in terms of
outbreaks
uh hospitality in particular and um
some of our larger shopping venues where
we've worked with a number of different
um stores and retailers we have done a
huge amount of prevention
work with the trafford centre in
particular um
doing three different community
engagement sessions with their staff
to train them up in contact tracing the
other area as well that i just need to
touch on is
a number of testing exercises that we've
run
in our high schools and with our primary
schools so with our high schools
we have done testing stood up testing
sites
um in flixton stretford high
and sale sale high and we've had an mtu
which is a mobile testing
unit which does pcr testing at our
primaries so last week
we did uh the firs and this week we're
doing
acres hall and the reason why we have an
mtu and a pcr
testing unit for primaries is that we
don't really test the students because
they're too little to be tested
we might test some of the year sixes but
this is all about capturing families and
carers as they come onto the playground
to drop their children off
and do some testing that way and that's
been brilliant and
uh just to thank nigel's team in terms
of the engagement that they do with the
community in terms of getting families
there as well to test
so i think that's everything at this
point in time um
and the other thing is just to mention
that at the moment we have no outbreaks
in our um
care homes which is uh something that we
are incredibly
um thankful for i think because that is
the area that we do
um feel most anxious about so that's a
quick
update it's not the news that we all
want to hear but you know
things could be worse i suppose looking
for a silver lining somewhere
so thank you thank you helen and before
i invite questions i
i do agree with you that school seems to
be the major issue
uh for us at the moment and as a chair
of governors i'm well aware of the
the outbreak management uh facilities
and the work that you're doing there and
we're very grateful of that
can i invite questions please to work to
helen at all
yes councillor blackburn okay
thank you very much um i i look at the
uh
the scores on the doors out sort of
every day and started looking at last
night
it said that um we as a borough it had
only gone up 15
since last week which is a great
decrease
because a few weeks ago it was like 42
increase
could ask it um what do do we know um
sort of any data on
those who have had both jabs but have
got the virus do we have anything from
that at
all i'm gonna ask jilla to comment on
that council of blackburn as she leads
our vaccination work from public health
jilla thank you yeah um
the evidence for people who have had
both jabs is that that provides a really
good
level of protection not only against the
original
variant and the kent variant but also
this new delta variant that is now
dominating in particular it gives
excellent protection against having um
[Music]
the worst uh health impacts from covid
from hospitalization and and from poor
health outcomes
we we we know that it doesn't give 100
percent
protection and obviously the vaccine
doesn't
work with 100 of the population and
that's why we want to get as many people
fully vaccinated as possible and we also
know
that two doses of the vaccine whichever
vaccine it is
that you're having is uh definitely more
effective in protecting us
and protecting our loved ones and
communities and those around us
than having one dose so really important
that people get both doses
uh once you've had two doses then you've
got
a really good level of protection
particularly
in terms of hospitalization and becoming
really poorly from covet
okay
thank you all right linda
thank you are any further questions at
all
dorothy donald the evans please it was
just
um in response your response to the
question
um because in my community what i'm
hearing
is that people are some people are not
having the jab
because they are hearing that when
people have had
um the vaccination they are becoming
infected
so now i'm interested in the in the
response to the previous question
how are we seeing people who have been
vaccinated
becoming infected and we do understand
that there isn't 100
um protection but i think it's important
that when we are trying to
encourage people to take the vaccination
that we're open and honest about exactly
what's happening julia
thanks dorothy yeah so if i can respond
to that
um as i say it particularly protects
against the worst
health outcomes from covid it doesn't
offer 100
protection from picking up and
potentially transmitting
the virus so it is possible
um to contract covid after two doses of
the vaccine the likelihood of that
happening is really significantly
reduced
after two doses um and somewhat reduced
after one dose so again the message is
we need people to get two doses in order
to get the best
protection and i think the other thing
to remember is that it takes a little
while
for our immune systems to fully respond
to the vaccine
and so you don't have that full
protection until a couple of weeks after
you've had the job so there is also that
time lag to consider
thank you jilla are there any further
questions at all
mike cordingly council accordingly
thanks chair
uh just a quick question on um dropping
vaccinations uh that seemed to be going
on around the country but i haven't seen
i think there was some in bolton but
i've not seen it widespreadly used in uh
greater manchester um where people can
just turn up
um and get vaccinated i mean we've seen
the cues for them in london
um they see i i
i i was conscious that the message from
bolton was that
that actually did a very few people uh
once they got underneath it there was
very few people that were
um refusing the vaccine most of it was
difficulty in getting it making the
appointment and things like that
so the the drop-in system
seems to have some advantage in picking
up some of these people
um i just wondered why we is it a
greater manchester thing that we've not
had please
or if i just missed them maybe that
um counts accordingly i'm going to ask
if rebecca can comment on that please if
she's our vaccine sro rebecca
of course thank you helen um so in terms
of
offering um walking clinics we do have
some walking availability across
trafford and
we haven't as yet established a full um
pop-in site um but i will update you
as to our plans over the coming weeks um
for that in trafford
but at the moment most of our um sites
in trafford whether that be delivered to
the pcns or the pharmacies
are offering a mixture of booked
appointments and walking appointments
however we have had some feedback that
that is maybe not advertised as well
as it needs so that's something that
we're very much working with our
community engagement team on
um at the moment so the additional
clinics that we've put on
particularly across the north to address
access are offering some walk-ins
um but yeah i acknowledge that we can
probably raise awareness of that in with
some more focused efforts
thank you thank you uh
just going back to donald this point i
think the most hyper high profile case
i've read about as someone who's double
jabbed and effective is andrew marr
and he has actually put his experiences
on the bbc website
and actually has made the point there
that
the whilst he was ill and whilst he did
uh
contract coven again uh he was less ill
and he recovered very very quickly so
that reinforces
this idea that the the the the
vaccination does give you the protection
that you need
from being seriously ill are there any
further questions to talk about
obviously
khan khan mogul please thank you thank
you uh two points one
uh we are also actually hearing quite a
lot on the social media
that after vaccination
people are beginning to die and
i don't know where that information is
coming from but
is there any truth in that one the
second one is
uh we're also hearing that you need to
have a third
vaccination especially with astrazeneca
you need to have the third one basically
get proper production is that true
may i come in their chair and i'm sure
jillian will also so
um at the moment in trafford i think we
we don't have
any patient-specific data which shows
any correlation between
deaths or admissions in people who have
been vaccinated once
or twice or not at all so it's really
difficult to comment as we don't have
that
um patient-level data available in
trafford i think um i agree with the
chair we've had we've
recently heard about a high profile case
cases are very very low
and we've not had anything escalated to
us in trafford at the moment about any
patients who have been admitted or died
so without that local
data i think it's it's really hard to
comment but we've not got anything any
evidence which would back up that um
claim around deaths and in terms of the
third
jab or the boosted jab and at the moment
the um jcvi is currently considering
the um availability and plan for booster
jabs but we've not had that guidance
formally yet so we know it's in in
discussion
um together with the flu vaccination
program and whether flu
and covered vaccinations can be
delivered as one um
immunisation program but that guidance
hasn't come out yet as soon as it does
we'll we'll be able to update
thank you rebecca thank you carl any
further questions helen you've got your
hand up
i just wanted to add in khan that we'll
take that comment back to our engagement
team to ensure that
um a robust information shared around
the vaccine on all our kind of channels
and media
um outlets that we possibly can so
nigel's there just to
see nigel pop up on my screen just to
ensure that um all the vaccine
information is is really robust that we
share which is which it is
but it's just to counteract any kind of
false news that is appearing elsewhere
thanks thank you and i must say
as chair i do find it very concerning if
this sort of false information is being
put about
uh very much so thank you um
councillor blackburn you've got your
hand up again
yes could i just ask one thing um the
some of the the hubs are going to
stop being the central place for the
vaccinations
and are they going to to the chemists
now for them to do it
is there going to be an issue with
access i'm just thinking about parking
and
um you know for some people to you know
to get
to to certain chemists
is are there going to be sort of any
issues about that
um again i can respond to that thank you
councillors so um
the the two primary care networks which
have
um stopped provision of the vaccine
vaccine program are the
west network so they had sites in
partington
and at david hume and also the
sale network who were operating from the
life centre and the live centre remains
a hub
so it's been taken over by a pharmacy
but it remains the hub
and the car parking is marshalled um and
the two
pharmacies that have gone live in the
west are davies by myself
reid's pharmacy and in emerson in
partington they've been live for about
four weeks now i've not heard any
um issues about parking uh with the new
pharmacies i am however
however aware of some um parking issues
with our existing pharmacy site which
has been live since the beginning of the
year um
in temporally and that's due to some um
road works around the site but that is
being managed
through conversations with our council
colleagues and marshaled appropriately
but yeah we've not had any any issues
since the new pharmacies have gone live
okay thank you thank you very much thank
you rebecca
uh i don't see any further questions
um thank you helen and those who've
contributed
at that point and uh coming on to item
four uh sorry item five uh we had a
discussion uh last time and uh clearly
we're all aware of the mental health
uh impacts of the of the pandemic and
it's a paper that's been circulated by
jilla uh
to us uh in advance of the meeting which
i hope you won't have time to read
and uh on understanding the mental
health impact of the pandemic and i'll
pass you over to gila thank you chiller
thank you chair and yeah so
what i want to cover very briefly is
just
what impact kovid has had on the mental
health of the people of trafford from
what we know
and a bit about what people can do as we
emerge from the pandemic and from
restrictions
to continue to protect and promote
our mental well-being and resilience
and also thinking about what we can do
for our communities and
for trafford as a borough to ensure that
we have
mentally healthy communities where
people can
feel safe and flourish and also
finally just a bit of signposting
for those times when we do need to reach
out and ask for a bit of extra
help and support so i think one of the
things about
um the kovid pandemic is that
it has surely impacted on
pretty much all of our mental health and
while most of us will emerge without any
lasting negative effects
for some communities and some groups
across trafford we can expect a
significant worsening
of mental health and i've listed what we
think those
more vulnerable groups are in the paper
there
i think it's also worth noting that as
the more acute
physical impacts of covered on health
pass we can expect a long lasting legacy
in terms of the mental health
impacts um they're likely to be quite
complex and
quite long-lasting so we need to be i
think
prepared for that in terms of our local
data
we do have more people in contact with
mental health services
than ever previously recorded and in a
survey
um looking at the impact of covet 19 on
mental health
45 of trafford residents reported
high levels of anxiety and and finally
unfortunately we have also seen a
significant increase in the number of
suicides across the borough
in the last 12 months which is really
sad um
to see so what can we all do to promote
our mental well-being
i think the five ways to well-being
provides
a simple and evidence-based
aid memoir or framework that we can all
use
it's easy to remember and it it covers
um the five main areas that we can all
pay attention to
in our day-to-day lives to protect our
mental health
um there's a bit more detail in the
paper there but i'll just go through
them quite
quickly and the first one is about
making that social connection and of
course during
the pandemic um we've spent an awful lot
of time
isolated and distanced from one another
so this one i think is particularly
key um and while many of us are able to
get out and about more
we need to remember those people who may
still feel anxious
or not feel safe or maybe self-isolating
or maybe suffering um from conditions
that make it hard for them to connect
and and look out for those people
the second one is about physical
activity and we've got really good
evidence that physical activity promotes
mental well-being
it's associated with lower rates of
depression and anxiety
and again the lifestyle that we're
leading in the pandemic has been quite
sedentary for a lot of us
perhaps particularly for those of us who
are working from home
so um a few ideas there for how we can
try to build in physical activity
to our day-to-day lives and i'm sure a
lot of you
have already done that through the
course of the pandemic so perhaps it's
about kind of cementing those habits
and i should mention that the final
version of the paper does have an
additional bullet point in there which
was missed off the one that was
circulated so
uh that will be circulated afresh after
at the meeting um the third uh way to
well-being is really about mindfulness
and taking notice um of
the present moment and what there is to
be noticed in that moment and we do
spend an awful lot of our time
lost in thought um whether reflecting on
what's happened
or looking forward to what's going to
happen and there's really good evidence
that if we can pay more attention to
being present
that also has a really um beneficial
impact on our well-being the fourth one
is about learning and continual learning
through life we know that that not only
enhances self-esteem and self-worth
but also is a mechanism for social
interaction so it links back to
that first way to well-being in terms of
connecting us
and the final one is about giving
and we know that simple acts of giving
and kindness
are not only lovely for those that
receive but also good for the mental
well-being of those
on the giving end of that transaction so
um a few ideas there in terms of small
acts of kindness
or larger ones like volunteering in your
local community
that can also promote mental well-being
so those are some of the things that we
can all
do and then thinking about our
communities and what we can do
as policy makers uh within our
organizations
um it's really important that we are
engaging
effectively uh with communities that's
about building on the existing assets uh
within our communities and involving
communities in framing
um the issues that affect them and
working out with them the solutions
there's also a huge amount we can do as
employers
and at work and i mentioned already a
lot of us working
from home we know that has its benefits
i no longer have a ridiculous commute
but there
are some dis benefits as well and i
mentioned the sedentary aspect of that
and i'm sure many of you will have
experienced some of the other
difficulties with working from home not
having that
um face-to-face connection with our uh
colleagues for me being new to trafford
council i haven't met the vast majority
of my colleagues and i'm very much
looking forward to
eventually being able to and again
trying to build in physical activity
getting active during
the day and there's actually a link to a
guide there to working well
remotely which i'm sure that
people will find a helpful resource
so building community resilience we've
got a couple of
examples there that i've included in the
paper of some of the really good work
that
um we're doing in trafford in terms of
building
those six community hubs that started
out as covered response hubs
but which are evolving now to really
provide an important resource to
communities
to create healthy and resilient
communities
it's about building back better and
ensuring that we continue to look out
for one another with
within our communities and support the
mental health of communities and to that
end as an important strand within that
work
around building up the skills and the
knowledge
specifically around mental health and so
there's a significant training offer
that we're putting together
um to that end we've also got an
existing
social prescribing offer across trafford
and
actually three-quarters of the people
referred into social prescribing
do have a mental health issue and those
link workers
can work in a very personalized way
with people to help them connect into
their communities
to help them find non-medical solutions
and to improve their mental health
and well-being and then the final
section of the paper as i say
is just a bit of sign posting because
there will be times when we do need to
reach out and there's a few pointers
there
in terms of the signs to pay attention
to when actually we might need a bit of
additional help and there's a list of
the sources of help
across a whole range of uh different
mental health issues there in trafford
that people can
access so i'll pause there but i'm happy
to take any questions
uh thank you before i do invite
questions uh
can i just make it clear to to this
group that any discussions
i don't want to see descending to a
debate on availability
quality of mh mental health services
across trafford
or criticism of the provider the
manchester mental health trust
because that is a matter for other
committees to actually examine in terms
of scrutiny
but there is a question coming in and
i'll invite council accordingly thank
you
um thanks chair and thanks jayla i think
it's a really useful report
um i think the the one aspect that i
would add to your list of things
in a sense we're doing it now with in
this very act of reporting to the
committee i think it
it's really important that we recognize
and get out there that mental health has
been affected
in the community and um and
and giving in a sense of permission for
people to recognize
that um i think to a certain extent
we've
rather sort of this is nationally it's
not criticism
we've almost locked ourselves this is
what we've got to do we get on with it
we do it
um we're now moving into a sort of the
the disease that our approach to the
disease has evolved now and i think
we recognize that mental health has been
affected and
and some of those key metrics in there
like the most obvious one is the suicide
one
i personally i it's always a difficult
one do you publicize the amount of
suicides we have or do we not
i personally think you know people like
churches and faith leaders and what have
you i know
communities should should be aware of
that change um
but that that that's my view and i think
it needs to get out into the community
that
your neighbor is likely to be depressed
and um
affected i don't mean um your particular
somebody who is a neighbor i saw the
frown on the chair's face
it's important to recognize it and i'm
really welcomed this report
and i know the press take um an interest
in these meetings i
think these it's more useful than most
things that we
we've had actually to flag this um
so i i really appreciate the work you've
done sheila
thank you uh council accordingly and and
can i say in in agreeing entirely with
what you've said that
as a council we are going to be bringing
forward a suicide prevention awareness
course
available to residents elected members
all were all of our workforce um
councillor harding adult social care is
leading on this at the moment and we're
just finalizing the
the details because we want to be able
to to actually
monitor the uptake right across
residents and across elected members and
across
our staff of those participating in the
course it's a short course which we've
identified
and and i think that it's the right
thing to do so thank you
uh gillard you want to come back at all
thank you chair just
i think to um say
that perhaps one of the silver linings
of uh the pandemic is
that this gives us a real opportunity i
think
to tackle the stigma associated
with mental health problems simply
because
it's had such a widespread impact on
all of our mental health and
so i'd really like to seize that
opportunity
and to also do what we can um to
normalize
you know um you know that it's quite uh
understandable and a natural reaction to
a public health emergency that we should
um experience difficult feelings
distress
low mood anxiety isolation loneliness
and i think that really helps in terms
of tackling the stigma associated
uh with low-level low-level mental
illness so
um an opportunity
thank you jill are there any further
questions at all
i don't see any thank you so if we can
move on then to the uh
item six and start with mass testing uh
invite ben to speak thank you ben
thanks chair so i'm just gonna give a
quick update in terms of what we've been
doing um around testing and then talk
through some key messages
so in terms of our enhanced testing
program that we've had in place
since we've seen those cases um rising
traffic um
as helen said before we've done a large
amount of schools work
where we've seen i've been increasing
cases because the cases are risen in the
school
or in that surrounding area um in prime
schools as helen said we've been doing
testing compounds and cares with mobile
test units in high schools
um where we've done whole school logical
flow testing the key reasons for that
just going to give you that background
is a we know that people's testing holds
reduced
b tests at supervised sites are much
more accurate than testing at home
um see it reminds people how to test
accurately we have definitely have had
feedback from people saying oh i wasn't
quite doing that correctly
so it's been really useful to have the
team come in and explain you know
getting them a bit of the throat getting
them a bit of the nose
um and i finally also encourage these
people to start testing again for those
that have stopped testing so
we found it so far to be a really really
useful exercise
as well as it's been working with
businesses um to do case finding
where there's been an outbreak um so in
the past month
under this enhanced testing work we've
done testing at four primary schools
and handed out home test kits at another
um three high schools
um and some door knocking exercises um
antimicrobial testing for two businesses
so in total
we've done 2 940 additional tests over
and over that we would have done
normally so it's been a really kind of
fantastic team effort
from everyone within the testing team to
kind of you know get to that stage
um otherwise um to highlight that our
mobile test unit is currently one of the
um
most well used ones in the country so we
are trailing um
slightly extended hours for that and in
terms of key messages i was thinking
about this this morning
i think kind of before i get to you know
some of the main ones we've discussed
before
i just wanted to highlight why we do
this the reason for this is that
we don't test to to protect ourselves
we test to protect other people the key
reason for testing
is that it allows you to self-isolate it
means that you're not
like to pass it on to someone else so
it's it's all around protecting your
loved ones your friends your family your
co-workers
and that's really really important to
emphasize um
so i guess yeah our key messages are
keep doing um twice weekly testing
um if your parent care was checking your
schoolish pupil now is a really good
time to check that they are still
testing
and if your business especially in
hospitality twice weekly testing could
be the thing that stops your business
from to close because you'd not be able
to catch in time
and this is a bit more difficult one try
remember to register your tests
i know it's a pain it is an absolute
pain to have to go through that process
of registering the test afterwards
but it does give the national team a
better idea of positivity rates
so you know if you're able to do so
please please please register those
electro flow tests at home
and then obviously finally do not use
electrical flow test if you have any
covered symptoms go get yourself a pcr
test
you can go to a variety of sites in
trafford we've got one in parts and one
at trafford park
the mobile test unit in stratford and
obviously some larger sites are
available
at manchester airport and the etihad so
there are a variety of ways to go and
get yourself
a pcr test and also finally a home test
kit
so that's all for me chair thank you any
questions at all for ben
i don't see any bent thank you very much
for that contribution
uh moving on to contact tracing
um is kate's on the call is she helen so
over to you thanks um so
just i did speak about some of the
issues we've been dealing with in the
general update
um but really just to say again that in
terms of outbreak management it is
incredibly busy but we are
well-versed now at working we have our
models of practice which have
have been really successful um in terms
of the level two so the individual phone
calls that we do have to make where
the national team hasn't been able to
get hold of them uh
an example of how busy it is for example
is
that this morning 55 cases came through
to be contacted by
staff in trafford so we are in the
process of standing up
a um contact tracing hub so until this
point with the services
that we had closed so access trafford
library staff and cctv staff have been
absolutely invaluable
and have picked up lots of cases for us
and have really kind of
embraced doing the contact tracing but
as our services
are reopening obviously it's it's more
difficult to
identify capacity from these services so
we are now in the process of
establishing
a permanent um contact tracing hub
within the town hall with four i'm
struggling with hay fever today i do
apologize
with four contact tracers who will be
there supporting
um the team throughout so that's a
really positive step forward for us
and and it kind of supports the other
services to get back to business as
usual as well
and the other thing just wanted to
mention is self-isolation pain
pilot which um kirsty johnson needs for
us and that is going from strength to
strength we've had lots of really
interesting case studies
which i'm sure kirsty will bring back to
uh pep for the next meeting if chair
would like that
but what i did want to want to say in
terms of what we're seeing
and i think it i think this is coming
from mixed messaging in terms of the
national road map
and uh current activity is um
some concern around whether people fewer
people are actually self-isolating when
their contacts
so we are aware and have worked with a
number of schools
where children have been seen out
playing even though they are contacts
so we're sending communication out to
all our schools today to cascade to
parents
to really kind of reinforce the
importance of self-isolation
in terms of preventing the transmission
um within our community so that's
incredibly important i would say
other than that we're just supporting
the schools really to get through to the
end of term they've got three weeks left
so again i would um ask all um
colleagues on the course
on the call just to be really mindful of
the pressures that our schools are under
at the moment
they're determined to get to the finish
line and we're determined to get them to
the finish line
um you know the schools have got
everything in place all the control
measures
the risk assessments and everything else
it's just trying to keep them
keep them on track to get to the end so
that's the main kind of focus that we
have in the outbreak hub at the moment
thank you thank you helen and yes it
would be very useful if we could have a
report
on that self-isolation initiative and
see
how traffic is comparing perhaps with
other boroughs in this
for a future meeting thank you any
questions at all for
helen i don't see any helen thank you
um so uh mass vaccination rebecca we've
i know we've touched on a lot of this
already rebecca but
carry on no problem thank you chair so
um
just in terms of an update for um
committee today we
obviously the guidance um came out last
week around the vaccination bowl over 18
so um we are currently working to
extend the offer we have our vaccine
schedule
deliveries right up until the week
commencing the 12th of july
so we've got plenty of vaccine in stock
um in both
astrazeneca and phi is obviously pfizer
for the younger
population and we are now doing a twice
weekly stock take of that vaccine supply
to ensure that we've got
um enough or where we've got surplus
making sure that we've got a process for
mutual aid around the borough
and to support and that increased uptake
we've also now had the data about number
of trafford residents who have um
access their vaccination through the
national booking system out of trafford
and today that's about 12 and a half
thousand and so that's likely to be the
mass vaccination centers but it's it's
helpful to know that there is access to
those of the centers and outside of
chapel for those that um
want it and we are on track
also to meet the offer to all of cohorts
one to ten by the 19th of july so that's
all
all over 40s um and the data is
suggesting as i say that we are
on track for 100 of offer there's
approximately 3 000 vaccines a week
needed to
ensure um uptake at a 90 level but again
we've got enough supply in the system to
be able to um
deliver that and as briefly touched on
before
we are now working with local business
owners um
across trafford to deliver some
additional
pop-up or walk-in clinics um in
collaboration with our business partners
um to address um a kind of working
population who might not be able to um
access the vaccine or don't wish to
access the vaccine elsewhere
and so we've had offers of help from um
john's ambulance in terms of providing a
vehicle to do that um pop-up
activity um and that will be in place in
the coming weeks
so that's probably the end of my update
thank you rebecca any questions for
rebecca from anyone please
i don't see any so moving swiftly on
then
community engagement nigel smith nigel
please
thank you chair so um can you hear me
okay i'm not here yes
for some reason i'm not appearing on my
screen um so
uh in terms of i think we've already
mentioned about there's a clinic at
the limelight clinic on a thursday which
is a joint
uh appointment and drop-in style clinic
so the engagement team are working very
hard to try and promote that clinic
so from one till seven pm in the
afternoon that is a fisa dropping clinic
in
in in the um in an area where we want to
see obviously
increased take-up of the vaccine so in
terms of promoting that clinic we are um
going to be getting the message out as
widely as we can visiting
businesses premises in that area for
example along airs roads with
leaflets and posters we're talking to
the local mosque around passing the
information on
we've also spoken to a voice of bme to
help their assistance with contacting
patients uh we've had a conversation
with
khan as well because they've got very
good contacts with the caribbean african
community living in old trafford and
hume to help promote that clinic
and we're also getting uh information
details about the clinic through the
local schools in old trafford
and ellie kadik the comms team has also
advised me that she will be um
following the pep meeting she'll be
circulating some details of that clinic
to the ped members
so that you have those details of the
clinic and able to promote it
as well uh the comms team will also be
down
at the clinic uh tomorrow afternoon to
take some uh
video clips and do some interviews with
uh the community engagement team with
the volunteers and with
the doctors there so we can use those
clips to help promote
vaccine take up again through social
media
a couple of things to report on we had a
really useful meeting with manchester
city council last week
to discuss how we can uh work better
with manchester in terms of that kind of
cross-border
issue that we've got there uh in in old
trafford
and uh sharing we're gonna have a
further follow-up meeting with around
sharing
our our combined ideas around community
engagement and
vaccine take-up we have also got
the nhs covid street team uh
you may remember they were out uh in
trafford on
christmas eve actually it was last year
and they are coming back to trafford on
saturday afternoon and
are going to be in the old trafford area
again
um doing similar works what they did
last year
but they'll be particularly promoting
the vaccine
take up and also handing out some local
information that we've got for them to
hand out so that'll be really useful and
hopefully we'll get some good insight
from them in terms of the conversations
that they
will have with residents i also want to
just to highlight the school's work that
we're doing
so yesterday we were at april primary
school in flixton
undertaking some community engagement
community listening work with parents
at school drop off pick off time similar
to what we've done with other schools
um and capturing feedback from residents
but also reinforcing messaging
around the testing vaccination covertake
behaviors and
the importance of self-isolation and
support that's available
we're supporting the mobile testing unit
at maker hall today as well and then
next week we will be doing some similar
engagement at
uh the first school in sail west
we're doing that on the tuesday but what
we are also doing on the monday is we're
going to be out in the community and
sail west
there's a community event the bread and
butter thing are doing
uh some food support work at sale west
community centre so we're going to be
tying in with that
we know there'll be at least 60 families
there and doing some wider community
work as well in sale west so that's
planned for next week
we also have a poster competition uh
with year six primary schools
uh focus on south by isolations that's
something that we're promoting to all
the schools in the borough
and for any schools that want to take
part there winning entry will make into
a banner which
that can be there at the school during
um
summer break and we've also undertaken
some engagement
sessions at broad oak uh school party so
i'm working with the infection
prevention control nurse as well so
we've done two or three sessions with
that school so lots of activity going on
to support the school so um that's the
main stuff i wanted to highlight
um we're at the moment in terms of
future plans we're looking at putting
together a
plan of action for around the summer
particularly you know around
with the schools being closed so looking
to link in with any kind of community
events
summer sports activities or out of
school activities that are happening at
the schools
and also we very much had a focused
conversation yesterday around
uh how we can um what is the approach
and messaging that we need to have
around that kind of younger population
and you know the 1830 age group and how
we can have some focus messaging at that
that
age group to in particular around
encouraging take-up of the vaccine so
that's all the work that's going on and
finally for me i'd just like to
again just push the community champion
scheme and we'd really like to encourage
as many people as possible to
to sign up as community champions and
all details of which on the scheme are
on the council website
that's it for me thank you nigel uh
are there any questions at all for nigel
from anywhere
uh chair yes council accordingly me
again
just a quick one uh nigel um the
the dropping at uh lime um
are we making it so that people don't
have to uh
have their nhs card and things like that
uh their nhs number
i think that i think that's something
that they've used in london
where you basically don't need any id or
whatever
and i think it's really useful it's not
just for people that might have um
questionable uh
it's not really for um people that might
be nervous of disclosing their identity
it's it's small for people that may have
lost it and then
having to dig around and get the same
sort of information
if they can just turn up and that i'm
really concerned
interested in that and can i uh put one
before we finish um and and then that's
the um
how we respond to um coming out of
lockdown in 15th of july
i want to flag that we've not mentioned
it yet but i think that's important
and it's going to mean a lot of
difficult messaging to go out
nigel
so in terms of the uh the clinton i
think rebecca's probably the better
position to answer that
uh my understanding is that you don't
have to have your nhs number that you
could probably have your address
but i think rebecca would be able to
answer that better than myself
of course thanks nigel so for anybody
that has
ever been registered with a gp and as
long as you can provide your name and
address
it will pick up your nhs number from the
national
spine we are aware of some pat some i
shouldn't say patients some people who
have never been registered with a gp so
for example
when we've done some vaccinations with
our homeless community or
people outside of trafford it does not
um
prevent you from taking up the vaccine
we'll still take details
and that will be registered on the
pinnacle system um it may not
necessarily
always show then on a record but it's
important that those people still have
access to the vaccine but
not having an nhs number does not
preclude you from having the vaccine
if that helps
thank you rebecca go on clemson wouldn't
it
it's not so much what happens that it's
getting people to the
the center first so why are we
making this clear before people turn up
because i think if they think they're
going to have to produce numbers that
they haven't got
they won't turn up in the first place so
it's important to get that message out
yes i'll go back to the community
engagement team on this but i'm aware
that there have been some concerns for
example
is this going to impact my immigration
status anything else so we have
that message is out and again if we can
do more then we will we will do so i
don't know nigel or julia if you want to
come in on that
i agree i think that's an important part
of the messaging to encourage people to
attend in the first place isn't it so
we'll certainly ensure that we build
that into the messaging
thank you thank you council calling and
can i just come back to council corners
point on the messaging
around when we come out of lockdown the
current assumption is
that all restrictions will end on the
19th of july but i think that we'd
further await a government announcement
around the 6th or 7th of july
and thank you for raising it council
recorder because i would expect us then
to start looking at our messaging
and there will be discussions with the
community engagement team about how
we're going to message depending on what
the government say
or announce uh in in the next week or so
thank you
um no further helen you've got your hand
up sorry
yeah i just wanted to mention chair just
about we've already had a meeting around
planning for the summer which obviously
goes across the 19th of july
and what we need to do as a team to just
ensure consistency and messaging
through to the next kind of september
time really
um so we have already started planning
for that but maybe
maybe we should bring back to the next
pub um some more thought through
kind of ideas and concepts around
messaging
for discussion that would be very useful
thank you
um i don't see any further questions
thank you nigel so we move on to uh
community enforcement and invite helen
grant helen
hi good morning chair and so you'll
remember that the multi-agency
enforcement group was meeting weekly and
we kept that as a weekly meeting
until both of the bank holidays in may
were out of the way that's now been
stood down to a fortnightly
meeting community safety were
responsible for the
residential covered breed and a stage
process of explanation
warning and then enforcement if
necessary and at the height of the
pandemic we were seeing 90 to 100
reports a week it's now exceptionally
rare for us to receive
a report of a residential coded breach
and that's also been the case with our
main housing provider
who attends these meetings as things
have got steadily a bit more
back to normal what we have seen is just
an increase in normal
types of antisocial behavior crime and
disorder
and so it's it's summer's a busy time
anyway
where we've been impacted disposed by
kovid is that we've had a couple of
staff who have been
in isolation as well so that's kind of
affected our
service delivery a little bit i would
say environmental health
are particularly busy at the moment
um in relation to businesses schools and
hospitality
i know helen went into those areas in
much more detail at the beginning of the
meeting so i won't
repeat what helen said but say
environmental health um
i think the word they use was swamps and
and then obviously as the measures ease
further
there's a lot of work by environmental
health in terms of
planning and for some of those kind of
larger events that may be
taking place what we also discussed this
morning
and not that we've had complaints about
this but something that our offices
and the environmental health offices are
seeing
is a reduction in face masks compliance
and so i don't know whether that's
because people just feel that
everything's getting back to normal
i know there has been talk around
releasing um
those measures or using those measures
and but also i think the warmer weather
doesn't help because people feel less
comfortable in a face mask when it's hot
um but environmental health have been
visiting kind of
shops and trying to encourage compliance
around
face mask use so that's kind of where we
are at the moment
our next enforcement group meeting is
next monday so it's been a week and a
half
and since we've had one environmental
health licensing and ourselves still
work closely with greater manchester
police on an operational and tasking
basis and just to kind of note
um our thanks to chief inspector nazim
who has recently
left his post to take up a promoted
position in greater manchester police
but
has been a fantastic support for us
throughout this process
i just wanted to to note that to the
group and that's my update if anyone has
any questions thank you helen um
before i invite questions i would say
that uh
you you i think you are writing
identifying the reluctance of people
or the reduction of people wearing masks
in and around places
and unfortunately this is possibly
uh to do with some of the national
issues that we've read about
in recent times where there is you know
i think people have lost some faith in
in messages that are coming out from
central government
um can i invite councillor blackburn to
ask a question please
thank you could i ask has there been any
indication
that there's an increase in wedding
receptions in people's gardens
um causing problems
not not in terms of complaints that have
come to community
safety and it isn't something that
environmental
health have flagged with me either
um but i can ask that question and
report back at the next meeting
just thinking it because a lot of people
um they've
cancelled their news because of because
of numbers
and they are holding their
you know their reception as such you
know in in their own home in the garden
and with it you know being better
weather
it is obviously you know outdoor events
but um
you know so i know i know it's happening
but you know whether or not it's going
to
cause an issue or you know as a spread
of anything i'm not sure
so i just thought i'd flag it yeah and i
suppose it's whether
neighbours are probably less likely to
to report something like that if it's a
wedding i think they're more likely to
report
issues where there are elements of
anti-social behavior such as loud music
rounded behavior
drug taking that kind of thing um
but certainly not that's come through to
community safety
thank you helen uh helen you collins
please
hi i just wanted to um share two points
is
around the face mask wearing so we um
are working with a number of large
retailers at the moment alongside
regulatory services
feedback is the concern around the
challenge that they get when they tackle
people
who aren't wearing the face masks and
that can also include physical challenge
so it is very difficult so we have
worked with a large retailer last week
who is now looking at a different
approach to de-escalate
but to encourage because at that point
they were saying we weren't challenging
because
it just felt too scary but now they're
going to ask and if people
um respond negatively then step back but
it's about that just reminding people
isn't it that face coverings
and the other thing is that um a
communication's going out
via eleanor today to all parents across
trafford
just to remind them that if their
children are contacts and they must
self-isolate
and then the legal implications of if
they don't self-isolate and obviously
enforcement with families is something
that we've tried to not
do because it's a very difficult and
unpopular
um situation but given the current
rates of transmission in the community
it's something that we really need to
reinforce uh we have had lots of
information
of uh head teachers for example going
down to the local parks at lunchtime
because bubbles who are out are all out
playing on the park
so um we shouldn't be having our head
teachers having to do that kind of
responsibility so it's just a real
strong
reminder so um any support that board
members could give us around
self-isolation would be really helpful
thank you
thank you helen are there any further
questions at all from
members uh
judith and just to say i i
kind of noticed that not only the mask
wearing uh
that people aren't doing that they also
um you just have to queue in the
supermarkets who will she
to use the uh sanitizer and i'm not
and whitening basket or trolley and i
don't think that's happening
uh as much there does seem to be a bit
of relaxation
um on the rules but
covid is a nasty disease and i think
people still need to be
careful so anything to promote that
would be good so thanks helen
thank you judith um any further
questions i
i don't see any other business at all
today
i don't see it as well we've done very
well on time
before i close can i well in closing can
i continue and just say from the chair
thank all of our staff public health
environmental health the ccg community
engagement our community champions
and our volunteers for the continued
hard work that they're doing
right across this borough you know
heartfelt thanks from me as chair here
um and you know it's just a shame that
our rates are where they are
however i'm sure with perseverance we
will eventually start to see them
coming down again we meet again in two
weeks
thank you very much all for your
attendance this morning
have a good day
bye